This news just in to CNN
in our health lead.
The Supreme Court has blocked Purdue
Pharma, the massive manufacturer
of OxyContin,
from going forward
with bankruptcy
proceedings
and a $6.6 billion settlement.
This was part of an arrangement
that would ultimately offer
the Sackler family,
the founders of Purdue
Pharma, Broad protection
from opioid related civil claims.
The Supreme Court says
they will now
take up this case and hear arguments
about it in December.
Let's bring in CNN's Jean Casarez
and Joan Biskupic.
Jean,
what exactly was in this settlement?
Well, first of all, when it began in 2019
when the bankruptcy
was declared by Purdue Pharma,
all of the civil suits
and there were so many around the country
against the Sacklers,
against Purdue, Pharma,
they all were channeled
into the bankruptcy action.
That was one of the first things
they did.
And people need to realize
how huge this was.
This involves states
This involved counties.
This involved townships.
This involves tribal nations
all over the country.
I remember being in the courtroom
and it was
filled with attorneys, attorneys
by phone all over the country.
So they started negotiating.
They've been
negotiating for years on this since 2019.
And they finally determine
And and there was a handful of states
that were opposed to this.
But it was really symbolically
at the end,
they decided that what would happen
is that the Sacklers would pay out
approximately $6 billion
to individual claimants,
to states, to abatement procedures
involving crisis medications
that could be given to people.
And in lieu of that
and their names
would be taken off buildings
around the country.
Also that was part of it.
But in lieu of that,
they would not face civil suits
going forward
because the money would be going toward
everything that I just described.
And here's the impact of this.
Those people that were the victims
and that
they wanted
money
and $6 billion is going to all of that.
This will be stopped in its tracks.
So no one,
no community, no
abatement proceedings,
no medications will be going
for the short
term to those entities that so need it.
Joan, are you surprised that the U.S.
Supreme Court
has not only blocked this settlement
that had been agreed upon,
but that they're also going to
take up the case?
Well, Jake,
those are pretty dramatic terms
that Jeanne just outlined.
And the solicitor
general of the United States
actually used them in her arguments
to try to get the Supreme Court
to intervene, to say
this is a very exceptional agreement,
unprecedented.
The scope of it is something that
maybe should be blocked.
And in encouraging
the justices to take it
up, say look at lower courts to divide
out there on situations
when companies, when parties
can be released from liability.
So it is in some ways, it's
surprising that they're intervening
at this stage.
But this is the most crucial stage.
And they have set it
on a pretty fast track.
They've ordered a fairly quick
briefing schedule.
And the case
would be heard
in early December
with a resolution, Jake,
probably by the end of June of next year.
So, you know,
when you think of the opioid
opioid addiction
crisis in America
and the responsibility of Purdue Pharma
and the Sackler family,
this is a
pretty unprecedented settlement.
So that's why the Supreme Court
has intervened at this point Jake.
All right, Joan
Biskupic and Jean Casarez, thanks.
Let's
bring in the attorney general of Ohio.
Dave Yost.
Ohio is one of the eight states
as well
as Washington, D.C.,
that are part
of the $6 billion settlement.
And you might remember Ohio
as, of course,
tragically, one of the epicenters
of the opioid crisis.
General Yost, thanks for joining us.
Did you want the Supreme Court
to take up the case
or did you want them to allow the
settlement to move forward?
We one of the settlement to move forward.
This is money
that it's not flowing to individual
claimant families. It's not coming back.
Equally important to our communities
and to our states
to fight back
against this avalanche of addiction
that was architected by the Sacklers.
What is the
I'm going to ask you a kind of a question
I haven't asked anybody before.
What's the best argument
for the people who disagree with you?
The best argument being made by,
for instance, the solicitor general.
People who want the Supreme Court
to review this case.
They they
they disagree with the settlement.
I realize I'm asking you to state
something you don't agree
with, but what is their best case?
Well,
I think there's probably
two arguments on the other side.
The first is that there's a lack of
due process in the in the
discharging that it's just
fundamentally unfair
to let the Sacklers walk away.
The problem with that
is that under the law,
we can get to Purdue Pharma.
The individual family money that's behind
that is much more difficult
legally in most of our states.
The other issue,
which is kind of a policy issue, is
what do we do with these mass torts
that are so massive?
There are existential lawsuits
And to maximize
the recovery for the wrongs done.
You have to have some kind of means
of marshaling all these claims.
And this is going to be
an interesting argument
of the Supreme Court
and your argument is correct me
if I'm wrong.
There are people in Ohio
and the other states who need help now
who need that money now.
Organizations that need to help people
who are still suffering
in this epidemic
that continues
to take thousands of lives a year.
Is that right?
That's absolutely correct.
And as the court of Appeals said,
bankruptcy is a creature of compromises.
It's it's
it's a
messy process of competing interests.
We've seen some preliminary data
showing that drug overdose deaths
have leveled off,
but still more than 100,000 Americans
losing their lives from overdoses
nationally, most of them,
I believe, opioids.
How is Ohio working
to alleviate the crisis?
Well,
we have a coalition,
we call it the one Ohio Foundation
that has all of our local government
and the state government.
We're sharing the money
from these various lawsuits
to bring it back to the local level
for treatment for poor, for prevention,
for enforcement, because this war is
fought on the ground
of our streets, of our cities
and our counties
and it's so important
to get this money flowing.
It's been since 2019
that this bankruptcy proceedings
been going on.
I guess the best thing I can say
about today's decision to hear the case
is at least they set it for December.
Yeah.
Can you imagine
if terrorists killed
100,000 Americans a year
But this is us doing it to ourselves.
Ohio Attorney General Dave Yost,
thank you so much for your time.
As always, we appreciate it.
Thank you, sir.